problem
yes thank you you motivated my talk very
well
so it's the fine grained counting
complexity that i will talk about and i
will start with counting because most of
you are familiar with the fine grained
part
and this is the first part in the series
the second part will be given by radu
who is probably watching at home
so
let us look at the
50 shades of
fine grained
so we have different problems here
and reductions between these problems
so a lot of focus has been
on polynomial time algorithms and trying
to show that they can't be
improved and
the eth and the strong eth are
hypothesis used in the that can be used
in this exact algorithm framework to
show that you can't get faster exact
algorithms
but eth also implies that
parameter right this parameterized class
w1 is different from fixed parameter
tractability
so using eth you can also rule out
fpt
algorithms
and what i will talk about today
is counting
so we will look at yet more hypothesis
maybe the counting exponential time
hypothesis
this one is implied by the eth and
rado tomorrow we'll talk about the
counting w1
classes so
fixed pyramid attractable counting
problems
so the outline will be to
look at the classical case first so the
polynomial time setting
since i'm sure not all of you are
familiar with counting complexity
then we will put on a fine grained lens
look at some specific problems and i
will mention some open problems
so in the classical era we were looking
at polynomial time algorithms
this looks like ruins but really it's
beautiful structures that we built in
the polynomial time world
so classically we
make this decision this
distinction between decision and
counting as follows so the decision in
the decision world we look at sat is a
cnn formula satisfiable
and np is in the class of problems l so
let me write them like this so they're
not subsets of
words
they're not sets of words they're just
functions
that map words to zero one that's
equivalent of course
and np contains all such problems that
reduce to set
under polynomial time many one
reductions
and in the counting world we can do
something very similar we can look at
number set
which is the problem where you're given
a cnf formula and you want to know how
many satisfying assignments there are
and then we can define a class sharp p
or number p
which is the class of problems where the
output is now not just zero one but it's
a number of satisfying assignments for
example
and sharp p contains the problems after
reduced to a number set
and of course here it's not clear
what it means to reduce
between counting problems it's not clear
directly what this means so let me give
an example
so if we have this small graph
and we want to count all hamiltonian
cycles there are like three of them
then we can reduce this problem to sat
as follows we can map the graph
to a circuit c it's a boolean circuit
and its input variables are
since we're looking for
a subset of edges here
the input variables will indicate
whether the edge is in the subset or not
so we have
one variable one boolean variable for
every edge
then we can construct a circuit
efficiently
and it's a polynomial time
polynomial size circuit
so that the circuit accepts if and only
if the structure that we see
is
a valid hamiltonian cycle
so this is a
very like
i'm just saying this problem is in np
i'm saying this in this fancy manner
but
note that this reduction
preserves exactly the number of
solutions
so if we had three hamiltonian cycles
here we will have three satisfying
assignments
down there
and this is the type of reduction
that we use to define a number p
so it's a parsimonious reduction our the
reduction r is called puzzymonius from f
to g
if
so f and g are counting problems
and we want that the number of solutions
to the instance x is exactly equal to
the number of solutions of the instance
r of x
and we want this to hold for all inputs
r
x
so this is a parsimonious reduction
and
number p is then the class of problems
that possibly polynomial time reduce
to number side
or equivalently we can also look at a
machine model here we can look at the
number of
non-deterministic runs that lead to an
accepting path in a turing machine
that's the very same thing
if you think about it
but since we're in fine grain complexity
it seems
like
we define complexity classes using
problems not machine models so i chose
this route
so and why is counting interesting well
counting is interesting because it's
harder than deciding
right you can easily find like a
solution here but if you want to
look at or count all solutions you sort
of need to look at the whole solution
space
in some sense
and this is made precise uh in this
theorem
namely the whole polynomial time
hierarchy is contained
in
in p when you have access to a number p
oracle
like uh
counting the satisfying assignments for
example so this means that we can if we
can count solutions to three cnf
formulas
then we can actually decide quantified
boolean formulas
so quantified boolean formulas are just
exist for
formulas like this boolean formulas
and the star means that we can actually
only decide uh quantified
boolean formulas if the quantifier
alternations
the number of them is constant
because that's
ph if it's unbounded we would have p
space and this class is contained in p
space so in some sense this counting
p
class is sandwiched between
finite alternation
quantified boolean formulas and
unbounded ones
so number p in particular number p is
much harder than np
so that's why counting is
sort of interesting from a complexity
point of view
let me give you some examples
so we've seen that you could count the
number of hamiltonian cycles but you
could also look at an optimization
problem like
compute the size of the largest clique
formally there's also
a counting problem
and you could look at algebraic problems
like
the input could be a matrix let's say
with small
integer entries
and you want to compute the value of the
determinant of this matrix that's an
algebraic problem
and this problem turns out to be number
p complete using the standard
np hardness reduction
which turns out to be to preserve the
number of solutions exactly
on the other hand
a problem such as this an optimization
problem is not likely to be number p
hard because this problem is actually in
p to dnp you can
guess the largest clique and you have to
verify that it's that it is the largest
clique
and the determinant is in polynomial
time
so they they can have different sort of
uh
can fall into different classes these
counting problems
so what's the most
interesting counting problem
uh or the one that has been studied
first
uh from a complexity point of view
that's counting perfect matchings
uh let's look at counting perfect
matchings in bipartite graphs so on the
left we have a buckethead graph
and these are all perfect matchings in
this particular graph
and let's say
there are d plus d vertices so d on the
left here on the right
then we can turn this into a matrix a d
times t matrix a
it's not quite the adjacency matrix but
it's some kind of bipartite adjacency
matrix where
aij is one if and only if i j is an edge
and then the number of perfect matchings
turns out to be exactly equal to the
permanent
and the prominent
let me define it for you is
this uh quantity so you
sum some overall permutations
so note that you can look at these
perfect matchings as
a mapping from the left to the right
like a function
and that function because it's
matching has to be bijective so it has
to be
it's a permutation
so that's why something over permutation
here makes makes sense
and then
this predicate so the product just
checks that the given permutation the
given matching
is actually a matching in the in the
graph
so if we just put one here then we have
the number of perfect matchings in the
complete bipartite graph
and with this predicate we count the
number of perfect matchings in in the
graph that we care about
and
how can we compute the permanent well
one way to do it is to do it naively
so we just take the sum over all
permutations
and then this this predicate can be
computed in polynomial time
for each pi
and this just takes time d factorial
roughly so so let me disregard
polynomial factors this takes time d
factorial
um but um
we can actually if like fedor talked
about this yesterday we can actually
often improve the factorial type bounds
to something faster
and something that will help is
that we can compute this quantity in
polynomial time
because uh
the products and the sums are are all
bounded polynomial bonded so why why
does this help well if if you multiply
this out if you were to multiply this
out of course we don't want to do that
because that would be too costly
then you would take the sum over all
functions
because i every i gets mapped to every j
so if you get all combinations and this
means that you sum up all functions and
you get all of these monomials here
that's that's good because the sum
contains as a sub sum all permutations
but of course we overcounted
so we need to sort of subtract all
functions that are not permutations
and such a function turns out to be not
a permutation if and only if it's not
subjective
yes
um
so why so so what do we do first we
subtract all
functions of all monomials corresponding
to functions that don't hit a certain
index j and we do this for all in the
indices j
so now we have
all functions that don't hit a certain
index but they might
also not hit some other vertex so
yeah so so we are under counting again
here
so i'm just saying we do inclusion
exclusion here so so we have to add
those functions again where we miss two
vertices
in the output
and so on so there are
uh
just a few steps of these well
exponentially many steps but if you
write this out
you get riser's inclusion exclusion
formula and this is a really old formula
so we just sum over all sets s
of indices that we want to avoid in the
output
and then we have some minus 1 plus 1
depending on where we are in this
process
and
then this product
this sort of polynomial
this this product can be computed in
polynomial time
and it's exactly this sum of all
functions
so so
uh what this means is that
ryze's formula gives an algorithm for
the permanent that runs in time d to the
d times two to the d
which is
well
much faster than
d factorial
and then so the from a fine grain
perspective this is great
but um
yeah why why should it be two to the d
why i haven't even said why it should be
polynomial time right shouldn't wait
can't be polynomial time
so let's let's start with
why
let's argue why it can't be polynomial
time
probably
so
and to do that let us compare the
permanent and the determinant so first i
will say that
passimonious reductions are not
sufficient to rule out
that the permanent is a polynomial time
and the reason for that is that the
permanent is actually easy in some sense
because it's so related to the
determinant it's easy
because mod 2 these two quantities are
equal
it's just a minus minus one sign if
you're taking mod 2 you get one so it's
they equal
and uh yeah many many algorithms and
fine grained complexity rely on this
sort of connection
um
okay so so this means that the permanent
cannot be parsimoniously hard because if
there was a puzzymonious reduction
then the number of satisfying
assignments
of the input formula would be equal to
the determinant of some output formula
mod
2. but we know that distinguishing
a formula having one solution from zero
solutions is probably a hard problem
so
under the using the isolation lemma we
would then get that rp is equal to np so
okay this this type of reduction does
not suffice all i'm saying is we need to
move on to
uh
two different types of reductions
and it's it's not
it's not 100 clear what these types of
reductions should be right so
in some sense
but we just use the most general kind of
reduction in polynomial time oracle
reductions so here the reduction is a
turing machine it gets a an oracle it
gets oracle access to g
and we just want that
f x
is computed by this oracle turing
machine when it gets access to the
to the oracle
and under this type of reduction
uh valiant actually showed in in this
classical result
that
numbers are reduces to the permanent
so if the permanent is polynomial time
then the polynomial time hierarchy
collapses
so we don't believe this is true but i
said
the parameter can be computed in two to
the d and in terms of fine grained we
want to know can we do it
faster at all
um
in order to in order to get there we
need to sort of review the proof that
the permanent is hard
and i will actually show you one that
you might not know except for maybe
one or two people in the audience
you see who one of the person
one of the people is so it's a reduction
from three dimensional matching
so
there we are given
the set system so every set has size
three
every vertex has a one of three colors
and every set
is multicolored so it's just a three
part tied three uniform hypergraph
and we want to count
structures of this type namely subsets
of edges
n over three of them so that
any two of them are disjoint
that we call the 3d matching
and i won't i won't do this here but
it's a fact that the reduction from
three-set to three-dimensional matching
is actually possible news if you just
work out the reduction
it turns out to preserve the number of
solutions exactly
so this means that we can start our
reduction to the permanent from this
problem
so the reduction
remember it's an oracle reduction so we
want to compute
the number of three-dimensional
matchings
and as an oracle
let's say we
as an intermediate step we don't use the
permanent but we use
size n matchings
in a bipartite graph with n plus three m
vertices
so so n is the number of elements the
number of vertices in the input and m is
the number of sets
and the way we do this
the way we do this is as follows so we
take any set
and we replace it with some gadget that
is a bipartite graph
so
for every set we introduce three new
vertices in this bipartite graph and we
connect them like that so the three
vertices are all connected to to so it's
a k32
with
two of the vertices
but only one vertex here one special
color class the first color glass is
connected to the first edge there
to the first
set vertex there
so that's the gadget
right so in the bottom we will have
so in the bottom we will have n vertices
and up here we will have
three m vertices
and then
what does the set gadget do
well if the set is selected we sort of
want to
so we sort of want to make sure that if
the set is selected
then then we can
then we know
how many
in how many ways there are matchings on
the on this set gadget
okay so if it's selected let's say we
call it selected if the special color
vertex is actually matched to a vertex
in the in the set gadget
so in this case we have two matchings of
this type
but then there are nasty
cases where
the set gadget is only partially matched
so some of them are left free and we
want to we want to rule that out
because this would mean that the sets
in the input are not disjoint
when we choose them they are not a 3d
matching so
so whenever we have at least one edge to
a set gadget we want all of them to be
there
okay
let's just look at the case here where
uh one of them is missing namely this
this leading edge
so let's say this one is missing
then
and all others are present
or two others are present
then the total number of matchings is
six
okay and now uh
those of you who have seen this type of
argument before we'll see that
well there's a difference between two
and six
and
in particular
if you count mod 3 if you count mod 3
this will zero out
this will be zero
and if you count mode 3 this will be
two
in particular mod 3 we know now that
um
every three-dimensional matching
leads to two
um size n matchings
well mod 3.
okay so we can relate these two numbers
and
yeah it didn't show all of the cases but
this also works when only let's say
this vertex is matched into the gadget
because then we have three cases and the
mod three are also
they also cancel
so the trick now to get this reduction
to work is to use higher moduli
so we can
this gadget works uh
for higher moduli two i mean there are
gadgets for higher modular and then use
the chinese remainder theorem
and this if you do this then you can
recover the numbers exactly
okay so let me
yeah i mean that you are using a
multiplication of the distinct brands
uh
what is it the modular
the moduli are all uh primes yeah
multiplication of my character liking
the
chinese remainder theorem
i don't understand your question
so if you okay
so if you know a number modulo
if you know a number modulo 2 modulo 3
modulo 5
up to
like
log n mini numbers
then you can recover the number
okay and now for the last step we still
need to reduce from um
from this bipartite version so k plus n
bipod graphs and we count k matchings
there so these are maximal or maximum
matchings in that graph
we need to reduce from that to the
permanent but that's fairly that's
fairly standard
uh so if we have a k plus n bipartite
graph on the left then we map it to an n
plus n by farther graph
by just adding
filler vertices and connecting them with
everything
and then so n minus k new vertices we
will have
and then the number of perfect matchings
in the in this new graph is n minus k
factorial times the number of perfect
matchings in the input graph
so so this means that from the number
here we can recover the number on the
left
so
let me just summarize
we went from three c and f side with a
passimonious reduction
and
so
and we use the chinese remainder theorem
to get
to three-dimensional matching mod d
or mod p
and we have a bunch of instances here
and then we use the simple gadget that i
showed you to reduce from each of these
problems or from the mod p version of
this problem to the mod p version of k
matchings and k plus n by partial graphs
and then we use the simple standard
reduction going to go back to the
permanent
yeah so this is a
very non-obscure proof that the
prominent is hard
or it should be
at least the gadgets all of these
gadgets are extremely simple whereas the
all reductions that i know
that have been used before
use these clause gadgets and i use uh
like this xor gadget or something
similar
when did it prove before
it was proved before of course
79
yeah this is an old one
um
okay let me move on to fine grained
well this is grain and we're going to
make it fine
and
so
let's look at counting satisfying
assignments
of cnn formulas there is very recent
work of ryan's and his goal for
that you can actually deterministically
compute
the number of satisfying assignments
of the cnf formula in a
time that's faster than 2 to the n
i guess his contribution was to make
this deterministic
so in particular the savings when f is a
casey enough formula the savings are 1
over k order 1 over k
and if f has c times n clauses then the
savings are 1 over log c
and this this sort of matches the
decision case where we can do this to
where we get similar kind of savings
and then sort of what we can do using
well
one hypothesis that we might have is
that this is optimal of course
so what is the hypothesis
number eth is just this hypothesis is
just eth lifted to a number side
the specification demo works
um just as before
yeah also it preserves the number of
solutions
yes
not our group not
well almost you just need to add some
small
variables that you set
so so okay so in your in the sunflower
argument either you pick the core or you
don't pick it and you don't pick it if
you don't pick it you need to set the
variables to zero then
it doesn't mess everything up it doesn't
no
yeah i checked this at some point
it's also published i just didn't want
to put it there
so the specification number oh what is
that
um yeah it
means we can assume that m
is
uh
order n
where the order only depends on k
um
and then of course we can formulate a
strong egh
for this sort of thing and this is a
weaker assumption so if s eth is true
then
yeah the number set is true so it's the
weakest assumption here would be
number eth
so let's look at the fine grain
complexity of the
permanent so just this year radu
improved improved our uh
so hardness result for the permanent and
he showed that
if the permanent can be computed in
sub-exponential time so
little o of d in the exponent
then number eta just falls
so yeah this work from before only could
show that the randomized dth is false
under under this assumption
then i want to mention
like work that's similar to like what
happens when the when the density is
so if
if the matrix has only a few entries
only
order and entries
that are non-zero
then the permanent can actually be
computed faster than two to the
d
and that's similar to the sad case
and this
state of affairs may motivate some to
define the
peth or path
uh which is that the permanent cannot be
computed in 1.999 to the n
or d rather
unfortunately i'm not aware of any
results that
start from here and reduce somewhere
but maybe
some of you guys can
uh correct me on that
is that in plain base
no so we don't know
we don't know the relationship between
path and seth
that's an open problem
okay and then then i want to mention
that
this somewhat surprising fact that if
you
count solutions of two scenario formulas
you remain hard
in particular and you remain number
eight hard
so what do we need to prove well we need
to reduce from
counting satisfying assignments of three
cnn formulas
um
to
the problem of finding satisfying
assignments of two theorems and how do
we do it
well we just use the specification lemma
first
which guarantees that every variable
appears a constant number of times
then we use this
new proof that the permanent is hard
and some little extra trick to get to
this problem which is that counting the
number of all matchings in the graph not
just perfect matchings all matchings in
the graph
even if it had constant degree this is
hard under strong engh and the number
stronger gh
and then from there we can get to uh
to this problem very very easily because
just look at any vertex it has constant
degree
and now for every edge
we add a
variable
and
for every vertex we add this set of
constraints
we can't pick x at the same time as we
pick y because then it wouldn't be
matching
and we do this for all pairs of edges
incident to to any vertex
okay so and then this shows that numbers
are for two cnfs
is a number
s eta chart
so this is also
a rather simple observation from here
so
now let's look at some
counting problems
uh
and on some progress uh or some results
in the literature
recording problems
so in
have we seen counting perfect matchings
in bipartite graphs
but what about general graphs
so so in byproduct graphs we have an n
half times n half matrix and then we
count the perfect matchings in the
bipedal graph with n half plus and half
vertices and that's
how we introduce the permanent and this
leads to a 2 to the n half algorithm
using riser's formula
and then andreas actually was able to
get this type of running time even for
general graphs
so we can count perfect matchings
in general graphs in time two to the n
half which is better than the obvious
uh two to the n algorithm
and i guess the obvious algorithm would
be two to the m
so it's even much better than that
okay another problem
would be cue color rings
so we could count
all
color rings proper colorings of a
certain graph
with cue colors
so so this problem leads to the
following
sort of interesting
object namely the chromatic polynomial
it's this
it's this function that maps a graph and
a number q to the proper
to the number of proper queue colorings
of the graph
and i want to argue that this is a
polynomial
it's very fast if you haven't seen it
you will
maybe enjoy this
so
if we have a graph and there is an edge
e
then
we look at the deletion contraction
the deletion of this edge e and the
contraction of this edge so the delete
in the deletion we delete the edge
and in the contraction we
merge the two incident vertices
and now it turns out that
if we count
if we want to count proper cue colorings
here
then
we might as well count all proper cure
colorings here
but
this doesn't quite work because we are
also
we would also count those q colorings
where the two vertices get the same
color
but we can just subtract the proper q
colorings of of this contracted graph
and then we exactly get
this relationship
the number of proper q colorings of g is
equal to
that of g minus e and that of g contract
e
and then in the base case we don't have
any edges left so we have k vertices
and then the number of q colorings is
just q to the k
so so using this argument we can see
that
this object is actually a polynomial
by induction on let's say the size of
the graph we can see this
and it has degree and
yes
well since we're counting color rings
parallel edges don't matter
so we would just remove them
okay so this is a polynomial
and how how fast can we compute this or
how fast can we compute uh q colorings
the the deletion contraction algorithm
i mean this this formula gives an
algorithm a natural algorithm that runs
on time 2 to the n
which is already faster than the
d to the or might be faster than the
q to the n
yeah
that would be the naive approach
um
okay and i think andreas mentioned
yesterday that you can indeed compute
this also in two to the n time so you
can replace the dependency on the number
of edges
with that of the number of vertices
and then under the eth we know that
there is no
two to the little of an algorithm for q
coloring
that's i suppose that's just using the
specification lemma and then following
the standard reduction
um
and of course we would
we would like to lift this to
uh
so number eth
but i will mention this later
so so let's first generalize the
chromatic polynomial so this will be
this crazy polynomial
and
i won't say much about it except that it
generalizes the chromatic polynomial
namely
if you plug in y equal to zero here
then
some instantiation of this gives the
chromatic polynomial
up to up to some factors that you can
easily compute
and the third polynomial has been like
heavily studied in counting complexity
and before that even it has been heavily
studied by physicists because it's
uh
it tells them something about the ising
model and the pots model and they have
long conjectured that the stat
polynomial is hard to compute
and this has actually been yeah proven
then
by this counting complex by the counting
complexity community
uh and apart from those there are many
other combinatorial problems
so the trivial algorithm to compute this
runs in time 2 to the m to the number of
edges
because the summation goes over all
subsets of edges
and some
almost all people are in this room have
proved that this can also be done in two
to the end time
um no all of them are in the room right
oh yeah yeah
and
on the complimentary side
like we
i i guess
so in 1990 they they did this
they showed that the top polynomial is
sharpie heart
and then we sort of lifted it to the eth
world and radu
uh with this idea uh
made it into yeah
prove that you cannot do it in two to
the little low of m time
under the number eth
and i will say
i will say in a minute how what the main
proof idea is here
um but what does it even mean
yeah we said that the that polynomial
generalizes the chromatic polynomial
so of course it's sort of generalizes q
coloring and we can't compute it in
sub-exponential time we already knew
that so what does this
even mean here
so let me just uh
i mentioned the the top plane so when
you fix x and y
they are just constants now
and uh for the for this or parameters
for this computational problem or
constants
and the input is a graph g
and you want to compute t
of g at this point x y
so then for every x y you get a
computational problem
uh and you can wonder how hard it is to
compute that problem
and every point actually corresponds to
some nice uh
combinatorial object and and you cover
many of them if you studied sort of this
and
study it in this setting
so the results
or i think the most recent picture of
what the top plane looks like from a
fine grain perspective is this one
yeah so for every x y we have a
computational problem and if you happen
to be
outside of any of these lines
x is okay
then
then your
number eth
and
if you are on one of the green lines
then
or points then you are pulling time
and the yellow the yellow line is open
so it's a number p heart
by this result from the 90s
but it's open
under
this should say eth and the strong eth
everything is open here
and the eth is open
and
let me just say
one i'll give you one case one specific
case where this is open it's this point
so this gives you a computational
problem namely this one so you're given
a graph
and you want to count
all forests
all forests
not just spanning first and you want to
have
a forest with
k edges should get weight two to decay
and if you don't know whether this is
hard under under egh
if you resolve it then
the top plane would there would be a
complete dichotomy which would be nice
okay so what is the method used here so
the method use this polynomial
interpolation
uh so so yeah in particular we know in
the top lane i said
if y is equal to zero
then we get a chromatic polynomial so we
already know that y equal to zero is
hard
everywhere except if you have one
coloring and two coloring these are
these points
yeah so this whole line is hard already
now we just need to sort of move off
that line
and we do that using polynomial
interpolation
so let's say we have a polynomial of
degree d
and we can somehow generate d plus one
samples which means we can generate
points where we evaluate the polynomial
and we can get
access to the
the value
um
then this is already enough to compute
the polynomial so we can compute all the
coefficients of this polynomial
in polynomial time that that's that's
what we refer to as or this is what
interpolation means in this context
and interpolation has been used a lot in
counting complexity
so for example in the or let's say the
top polynomial
just to give you something to think
about
and let's say it only has one variable
so we specialize it to a particular
line
or hyperbola actually
so it has degree m
and let's say we want to show that this
that evaluating this polynomial at a
certain point z is hard
so
what this means is that we need to
reduce to that
computation problem
from from some hard problem
and let's say
we know some point on this line
some sorry some point
in this polynomial already
is hard
so some point
let's say uh
at
17 if we plug in 17 we get the number of
16 color rings or whatever
and that that we already know to be hard
so we need to reduce from that
point 17 to the point z to to show that
it's hard okay
g of 17 would be a polynomial
tg17 would be a point
it would be a value
if you plug in
some value here
oh you no no so z the forget the x y
variables you you can be the only verb
you're the only person who can be
confused about this
yeah
just it has one variable that's fine
um
okay so we need to reduce to
that point and of course if we
interpolate the whole polynomial
then we can also compute the hard point
so we just need to interpolate the
polynomial that's the task
um
so what we would need is we would need
to come up with sample points c2 c3 c4
and so on
where we can also compute the polynomial
but of course we can't do that because
the oracle the only oracle that we have
is this one
so what do we do well we modify the
graph in some way so that the point
moves
so in order to compute the polynomial at
point z i we actually
move to a different graph gi
which we
plug into the polynomial
and and there we look at the point z
so the reduction is
in the third polynomial it often looks
like this like exactly like this every
edge
gets replaced by
a path
of length i
and it's called stretching
and when you do that you sort of mess
with the exponents
of z in such a way that you move that
point
um so so in order to
so in order to interpolate on this line
what we need is m plus one samples
because m is the degree of the
polynomial
and this also means that we need at
least m plus one different gadgets if we
use this approach because we
want to have different different graphs
here
but that means that the
size of the gadget has to be at least
logarithmic in the number of gadgets
that we need
or some gadget some gadget will have
size logarithmic in m
yeah so the total number of edges here
might get really large so if we just do
this path thing
then we might
square the number of edges
yeah every edge gets replaced by
a path of length m then we would square
the number of edges but fine grained as
a fine grained reduction this is not
good enough
if we're clever we could
get this path
or the same functionality as the path in
a log size gadget
but even that wouldn't be enough
so this argument just says that we need
a super constant size gathered here
and no matter what we do like univariate
univariate interpolation will only rule
out
running times of this form like
2 to the m over poly log m
under number eth
then
khardu's idea is to
not do univariate interpolation but
multivariate interpolation
so
if we think
or and and now i i sort of
chose to write down the thought
polynomial or some version of it
uh if we think of this polynomial
it's
q is let's say q is a constant it's like
17
so it's the line that corresponds to 17
color rings
and then
in z we have a univariate polynomial so
how do we get this to be a multivariate
polynomial
well we partition the edges
into n over r blocks each of size r
and each
block gets their own variable so we
don't just have one variable z for
the whole for all edges
but we partition the edges
and then we distribute
them accordingly to the to these new
variables so now we have a multivariate
polynomial
we have n over r of them
and the exponents here
they are just the intersection of the
set a with the n over r block for
example
so in particular the exponents are all
of size r at most because every every
block has size r
and then we can use multivariate
interpolation
um
and in order to do multivariate
interpolation we just need to evaluate
the polynomial where it's sufficient to
evaluate this polynomial on a grid
so it's an
r by r by r by r grid
where the number of dimensions is n over
r
yeah so we need to be able to plug in
are different values for all of the
different uh variables and do this
independently from all of them
so that's how we come up with the
why r to the n over r samples
are sufficient
and r to the n over r is
its sub exponential yeah so that's the
this sort of like cracks here
we can we can do this
we invest
a super polynomial but sub exponential
amount of time
but we can do this multivariate
interpolation then
in a better way why is this better
well we only need to plug in our
different values for each variable
so this means for each
um
each edge is assigned so an edge may be
assigned to a specific variable or is
assigned to a specific variable and this
edge only needs to be replaced with r
plus one distinct gadgets
it doesn't need to be
log m different gadgets
and r is a constant or we can choose it
to be a
uh constant we just need to find a
constant number of different gadgets
that sort of
make this exponent do some predictable
things
in order to do this interpolation
yeah so uh
this this approach this plug-in block
interpolation approach then
is able to rule out two to the little of
m algorithms under number eth
um
okay
any questions
and we move on
just i will just mention a couple of
things
nothing technical anymore
so
let's do approximate counting
i didn't get the joke what female
diamond yeah
it's a german idiom yes
yes
oh by the way all artwork that i use
all artwork that i use is in the public
domain so no one can sue me
um
i'm disappointed that you're using
pioneer tau but
yeah
okay let's do approximate counting
so
the permanent
you can evaluate the permanent
approximately if the entries are
non-zero sorry if the entries are not
negative
the entries of the matrix then you can
evaluate the permanent
efficiently meaning in time polynomial
in n over epsilon and you can
approximate it its value to a factor of
one plus epsilon
um
so this was proved the somewhat well
in the 2000s
and much earlier we actually knew that
you can approximately count
satisfying assignments to the cnn
formulas
when you're given access
to an np oracle
so if you
uh yeah and the idea here is that you
just query your article to begin with is
there a solution
if there is then
you
make it so that the number of solutions
gets divided by half and then you ask
the oracle again
and how do you divide the number of
solutions by half you just intersect the
solution space with a random hyperplane
that's sort of the basic idea of this
yeah and this classical result has been
recently lifted to the fine grained
world
which i find
very surprising
so in particular if cnf set is in 1.999
to the end so if
if strongh is false
then you can
approximate
approximately count the number of
satisfying assignments
also in sub-exponential time slightly
worse
sub-exponential time
and you can do this to a very uh
well
so some factor one plus epsilon where
epsilon is even sub exponentially small
yeah
of course uh yeah so this isn't the same
spirit as as stock meyer you assume
something we sort of don't maybe don't
believe i don't know
well np really believe but uh strong ath
maybe not
um yeah
so
let me mention some more open problems
namely
a lot of the counting
complexity
field
tries to get dichotomy theorems for like
classes of problems
i've shown you the spirit of one like
for the top polar number we have like a
whole plane
and we can classify them into two cases
um
either it's efficient efficiently
computable or hard
and in the same spirit we can we can do
this for lots of different problems
for constraint satisfaction problems for
example
we know that it's
so the constraints here the variables
are not necessarily a boolean domain
they're of a finite
domain so
so this theorem here says that
whenever we know the set of allowed
relations
then
we can sort of determine
um efficiently whether
the problem the constraint satisfaction
problem that allows these relations is
in p or whether it's a number p complete
so bulatov originally gave this with a
non-computable sort of rule
for whether it's in p or number p
complete
and these guys
made
that distinction efficient
very effective problem
um
yeah and then you might ask is there a
dichotomy under
number eth
and the same
sort of the same type of question you
can ask for weighted csp where every
relation also gets
a weight if it gets
used
and
you can also look at generalizations
or
related problems
you can look at a whole lot of problems
and ask there
whether you get dichotomies under eth
and this is my last slide before the
summary slide and i want to
go back to the question why we even
bother looking at counting
well
if strong eth is true
then
yeah this is going to be a bit gloomy
then c and f side isn't true to the n
number c and f sub isn't true to the n
and q f set isn't 2 to the m so they're
all sort of equally bad
so it's not clear why it even makes
the difference
whether we look at number eth or
or a number strong eth
but maybe my
one remark here is that in practical
applications so if you actually want to
uh
in like an actual set servers cnfsat is
much easier than qbf said
so what might still be interesting is
if uh there is a reduction from qbfset
to counting satisfying assignments of
cnn formulas
so this would be a like a total type
theorem in this world
and it would sort of show that counting
is
harder at least as hard as
a qbf
so
that will be all this is the summary i
put up some open yeah mostly open open
problems
thanks
the previous slide do we have any
complications
uh no
i mean
eth implies number eth but we don't know
anything
yeah we don't know that number eight is
harder than eth
any more questions
yes
in this result by trexler that you
mentioned on uh
from cnn set to accounting cnf set
is this
like if if there's a 1.98 algorithm is
outward this algorithm also improves or
uh
there's not like the the so there's a
direct correlation between
uh the the running time for the
algorithm for
c and f sub and the approximation factor
and the running time you get for the
counting problem as far as i'm able to
parse the statement of his theorem i
would say yes
so
if you have a 1.8 to the n algorithm for
cnfsat then you get a 1.82001
algorithm
for counting as well
for approximate counting
any more questions
thanks